hi everyone I'm Steve Brenton and this
is the first video lecture in a new
series I'm calling data-driven control
so the purpose of this course is to
start getting an understanding of when
traditional control methods start to
break down for real-world systems and
then start to leverage modern methods
and machine learning data science to
start to solve to start to solve these
problems for real-world control on
actual systems of interest so if we're
feeling a little ambitious we might even
go so far as to call this machine
learning control I personally subscribe
to the big umbrella view of machine
learning so lots of what I do I consider
machine learning whether or not it's
extracting patterns from high
dimensional data discovering models of
dynamical systems or learning control
laws directly from data so really this
is kind of modern mathematical methods
in machine learning applied to control
theory okay so the the goals here again
are to to get you introduced to thinking
about how these powerful modern methods
and machine learning can be used to
start to tackle real-world control
systems and this is not comprehensive
this is a very very fast and growing
field of applied mathematics and
engineering where people are using these
data-driven techniques for control and
so this is really just going to be the
tip of the iceberg but I want to get you
excited and I want to get you starting
to think about how you can use these
methods to actually control real-world
systems of interest to you okay
the background I'm assuming for this is
a basic appreciation of control theory
and some kind of you know basic applied
math so that when I tell you about the
methods of machine learning which is
mostly going to be framed in terms of
linear algebra you can follow along so
if you want to get a quick up to speed
background on control theory you can see
my control bootcamp series which is a
few hours to get you up to speed
just on linear linear control theory
okay so the motivation here let's let's
motivate why we need mod
in fancy and machine learning control
why doesn't traditional control work for
the systems of interest so back in the
you know the the last few decades
essentially what you would do for a
large class of control systems is you
would write down the equations of motion
for your system maybe I'm working on an
engine or an automobile or maybe let's
take a really simple example I want to
stabilize a pendulum and that pendulum
is on a cart that can move left or right
and I'm trying to stabilize that
pendulum on a cart so in the past what
we would do is we would write down the
equations of motion I would write down
the Lagrangian or the Hamiltonian for
this pendulum on a cart those would be
nonlinear equations which would be
difficult to control but what I can do
is for lots of systems of interest I can
linearize those nonlinear equations
about some equilibrium like the pendulum
up condition and then what I can do is I
get a linear system of equations and I
can use that with linear state-space
control theory that could be a common
filter with a linear quadratic regulator
it could be robust control all kinds of
control methods once I have a linear
system of equations ok so just to kind
of recap usually what I'm considering is
that I have some kind of a system okay
that system gonna have some outputs and
I'm gonna have some controller and this
is all just just review okay so the
controller has some measurements of the
system these are why my sensors my
sensors why sense what's happening in
the system and then that controller can
actuate the system it can push on the
system in the cart example it might be a
motor on the wheel that can drive the
cart left or right so these are you my
actuators and the whole idea in this
feedback control diagram is based on
sensor measurements of the system and
maybe some model of the system I can
design an actuation strategy that that
corrects and controls my system to
stabilize
for example the pendulum up condition ok
so this is very classic you can work all
of this out if you go back to the
control bootcamp for linear systems ok
but this is where it gets interesting so
those traditional systems like pendulum
on a cart or cruise control things like
that we could write down the physics we
knew F equals MA we could write down the
equations of motion we could linearize
them and then we could do linear control
theory okay that's what the vast
majority of kind of modern control is
based on are these linearizations and
linear control theory but in the real
world the dynamics that were actually
interested in are probably nonlinear
functions of X and the actuation you
okay so X is the state of the system
here the time derivative of F is X is
some nonlinear function f of the state
and the input U and so for nonlinear
control things get really really nasty
let me just give you some examples the
systems that we actually want to solve
today are for example systems in
neuroscience trying to understand model
and control what the brain is doing to
prevent seizures we might want to
control a turbulent fluid system so I
have a wing and that wing is at a high
angle of attack so the flow is massively
stalled behind it its turbulent I might
want to control that Andry laminar as
the flow to get higher lift and lower
drag okay very non-linear problem
disease modeling epidemiology maybe i
want to suppress the spread of malaria
on a continent okay
finance i want to regulate a financial
market or the climate i want to do some
kind of a feedback i want to understand
first of all the non-linear feedback
going on but then maybe I actually want
to design some control strategy to
regulate the behavior of the system okay
so these are all examples of modern
systems of interests that we actually
want to control that the traditional
write down an equation linearized design
and lqr controller are not going to work
for okay so I want to I want to start
thinking about what are these
fundamental limitations so what are the
challenges of these control okay so the
challenge is for all of those systems
let's say disease modeling turbulence
neuroscience finance climate
self-driving cars you name it anything
really really interesting that we
actually want to control in the modern
era some of the themes are that it's
massively nonlinear okay and there might
not even be a good state to linearize
around in in many of these these cases
and the turbulence example for for
example that's what I work on most of
the time there are lots of cases where
what I actually want to do is increase
the turbulence I want to increase the
non-linearity so that I get better
mixing so for example if I'm making
chemicals in a vat I want to stir it in
a way that increases the mixing that's a
very nonlinear control problem that you
can't write down as a linearization
about a stable or unstable fixed point
okay so most systems of modern interest
are very nonlinear what I think is
really interesting and this doesn't get
said enough is in the classical case we
had you know in textbook control you
open the textbook and you have the
equations of motion for the system
you're going to control we don't have
equations for the brain we don't have we
don't we can't agree on equations for
the climate even in turbulence where we
have the equations they're so big and
unwieldy we can't really use them for
online control so in many cases one of
the fundamental challenges is that the
equations are actually unknown so I'm
going to call this unknown dynamics okay
that's a really really big challenge in
many of these systems and it's
increasingly becoming a central focus of
research efforts as actually I don't
even know what F is how do I control
that okay another really important one
most of the systems I describe to you if
we were going to simulate them if we
were going to you know make a big
computer simulation they would be
extremely high dimensional what do I
mean by high dimensional I mean that
there are lots and lots and lots of
degrees of freedom required to describe
the system state X so for example if I
want to describe the spread of a disease
in a country or on a continent maybe at
my model would include every single
individual human as an agent and that
would be you know each humans health
state could be an entry in this gigantic
vector
or if I want to simulate the weather on
planet earth maybe what I'll do is I'll
break the the surface of earth up into
one square kilometer grid cells and I'll
run some kind of a simulation on that so
this X could have millions or billions
of degrees of freedom easily for all of
the systems that I'm naming in the brain
I think you have 100 billion neurons
something like that this is a huge huge
high dimensional X now why do we even
think that we can control these high
dimensional systems if there's millions
or billions of degrees of freedom how
could I possibly control X well this is
I think the crux of almost all of this
machine learning control is that in all
of these complex systems with high
dimensional non-linear possibly unknown
dynamics there tend to be dominant
patterns that emerge so in the disease
spread maybe there is an epidemic wave
and there is some way of characterizing
that with instead of a million numbers
maybe there's a few numbers that you can
use to approximate that spread
similarly with turbulence even though
there's millions of individual vortices
if I have a wing that's stalled there's
going to be large coherent structures
that are the most important for lift and
drag and mixing and things like that so
even in this million or billion
dimensional state space X there might be
a few numbers some low dimensional
representation some dominant coherent
patterns in the data that are actually
what I want to control their proxies for
for what I actually want to control
which might be lift or drag or
suppressing disease I think in in
neuroscience a seizures may be a good
example your 100 billion neurons start
to have this single coherent oscillation
that you would try to break down if you
wanted to stop a seizure okay so even
though you have super high dimensional
unknown nonlinear dynamics these big
dominant patterns manifest and you want
to control those patterns and then I
think another important feature to
mention is that if I have such a
ridiculously high dimensional system I'm
probably going to have limited
measurements measurements so I'm only
going to be able to measure some of the
states with Y you know if I'm going to
measure the ocean I can drop
Louise but it's hard to measure
everything all at once and I'm also
going to have limited actuation I'm not
going to be able to push on the system
everywhere I might have individual
locations where I can actuate so in the
disease modeling and control maybe I put
a vaccination station in a village okay
and that's one point in this large state
space or maybe it affects only a small
region of state space okay so these are
the fundamental challenges that motivate
this entire series on modern data-driven
or machine learning control we have
these fundamental challenges of the real
systems of interest they're nonlinear
unknown high dimensional and we can only
measure certain things about them and
what we're gonna do let's say the caveat
the the opportunity here is that in all
of those systems we are having an
explosion of data we have this this
massive increase in the data collection
capabilities that we've never had before
with high-fidelity simulations better
experimental measurement techniques
cheaper hard drives faster computers
we're having much much much better
ability to collect data for these
systems so instead of trying to you know
write down from first principles physics
what the equation of the brain is maybe
we should just collect more data and
start using kind of data-driven machine
learning techniques to characterize the
system and to start playing around with
designing control laws that's what this
entire lecture series is going to be
about is using these modern data-driven
methods to start addressing one by one
going through and addressing these
challenges to make control theory more
accessible to the real systems of
interest okay and I should note we still
don't have really you know any silver
bullets for neuroscience turbulence
finance climate epidemiology modeling
and control these are still open
challenges this is modern research I
don't want to tell you that this is all
done but these are the steps that we're
taking towards starting to break down
these grand challenge problems and make
them tractable and then start to get
towards the solution so those are the
solution that the problems of the modern
era and we believe that data driven
techniques are going to be at least a
part of the solution
combined with classical theory of
dynamical systems in control so we can't
throw away what we know about control we
can't throw away what we know about
physics but we're going to augment that
with the massive amount of data that
we're collecting ok good
so just a couple more things I want to
point out and then we'll break into
individual lectures and start to dive
into specifics and case studies and all
this one thing I want to get to is what
is control okay so in the first place
what is control theory so I have been in
the past accused of oversimplifying and
I think that is you know a risk you take
when you try to distill something as big
as machine learning control into a
single lecture series or even an
overview I'm going to oversimplify what
is control and what is machine learning
okay so what is control I think of
control as an optimization that is
constrained by the dynamics of of your
system the physics of your system so
this is a optimization that is
constrained by dynamics let's write this
constrained by dynamics okay so what
does the optimization look like this is
not the full picture in reality what I
probably have is I probably have some
disturbances and I probably have some
measurement of some goal of my system
maybe that goal is I'm just gonna say
goal this is super vague what I mean is
it's an objective it's a cost okay I
want to make my cost low or I want to
make my objective high so in this case
this could be making drag small lift big
on a wing okay and these disturbances
could be gusts or ice that's forming on
the surface of the wing or something
like that so really my system has all of
these unmeasurable kind of hard to model
and handle disturbances that are kicking
my system and trying to knock it off of
optimal and my feedback controller is
trying to regulate the performance of
that system to
by some desired objective or goal and we
do that we do that by designing this
control law and I'm going to
oversimplify here this u equals K of y
there's just some function some
nonlinear function maybe in terms of
past measurements of Y and some
differential equation but there's my
actuation is a function of my sensors so
I measure what my system is doing and
then I decide how to how to push on the
system with my actuation to get some
desired objective given some
disturbances and this all boils down to
an optimization if I had a linear system
if my system was X dot equals a matrix
ax plus bu we would have linear
optimization linear quadratic regulator
calman filter LQG those are all examples
of optimal control and when people say
optimal control what they mean is we did
an optimization to minimize a cost
function given some disturbances and the
constraints of the dynamics that's all
the control is it's a constrained
optimization where your system is forced
to satisfy some physics some
differential equation governing the
dynamics of the system okay now if I
have a nonlinear control problem I can
still write down an optimization problem
the problem is we really often only have
closed form solutions for linear
optimization problems so the linear
quadratic regulator is a great example
where if I have linear dynamics and a
quadratic cost function I can write down
a closed form solution for what u equals
as a function of either Y or X okay if I
measured all of X I would get u equals a
matrix times X and that's a closed form
solution of this constrained
optimization if I have linear dynamics
and a quadratic cost function but if I
have nonlinear dynamics and some weird
cost function then this this
optimization becomes really really nasty
and we don't have closed form solutions
and we might have to do that
optimization on the fly okay so for
example you know if I'm developing a
control system for a missile or for a
UAV or for some autonomous vehicle the
nonlinear dynamics and a nonlinear
objective I would have to be re running
this nonlinear optimization on the fly
and that's very expensive and that's
actually largely what is done nowadays
with model model predictive control it's
essentially this big online optimization
that you're doing that can handle a lot
more non-linearity okay
now this is where I think it gets really
interesting so we we're now framing
control as an optimization possibly
nonlinear possibly high dimensional with
some objective function let's think
about what is machine learning
okay what is ml you're gonna see me
write ml a lot that just means machine
learning so what is machine learning
I think of machine learning as a really
really powerful emerging set of
non-linear optimization techniques so
these are powerful non-linear
optimization techniques based on data
okay
so for example many of you are familiar
with these new powerful deep learning
techniques for image classification okay
so now you can upload an image and it
will tell you what the image is just
using machine learning using deep
learning that's essentially a big
non-linear optimization where you had a
ton of training data of labelled images
it's high dimensional because there
might be a million pixels in an image
but again there are these patterns
there's only a few categories of things
that those million pixels could
represent that's an example so machine
learning is this increasingly powerful
set of techniques for nonlinear
optimization based on data okay what do
we have in modern control systems if you
want to control a seizure or increase
mixing or you know increase lift on an
airplane wing that's a nonlinear high
dimensional optimization problem machine
learning is a set of techniques that can
help nonlinear optimization based on
data and we have an increasing amount of
data okay so that is really the mile
high view of what we're going to be
doing in this this video lecture series
is really starting to figure out how I
can use this to solve this for real
systems with real challenges
okay the last thing I want to show you
today is essentially just an idea of a
little bit more texture of how we're
going to do this how are we going to
apply machine learning to solve this
problem so there's a lot of ways we can
approach this the first one and I think
this is the one that has classically
gained the most attention is I can
directly use machine learning for
data-driven models let's just write this
down data-driven models okay so remember
one of the big problems is I have
unknown dynamics so maybe what I can do
is I can find some model of my unknown
system just using data I can collect
data of X and U and X dot and I can
learn what is f you know from from that
data so that would be using data driven
or machine learning to model the system
and then I might be able to use classic
control model predictive control or
optimal control once I have a system
model okay that's very very interesting
and we'll talk a lot about that so the
other broad category that I think is
interesting that we'll talk about in
this class is instead of spending all of
this effort building a model from data
which might be good it might be
interesting to learn what the physics
are right that might be useful for
interpreting what our control does and
what are what our system behavior is but
we always we know that once I even if I
painstakingly model the system when I
start to push on it with control that
system changes right the whole purpose
of control is to change the behavior of
the system so if I measure my climate
system just so that I can control it and
change it my model might become
invalidated pretty quickly with control
so instead of doing all of that
painstaking modeling maybe I should
apply my data driven machine learning
techniques directly to learning a good
controller so that's a really
interesting new and emerging field which
is essentially machine learning control
which is can I just directly learn
effective control laws this is very
similar to maybe what humans or infants
and toddlers do
when they babble and they you know play
around in the world and they're they're
curious they explore the system and they
try different control strategies and
they learn effective controllers and
actually I would advocate doing both of
these we should really be modeling the
system and trying new control laws in
parallel so really doing both of these
at the same time it's probably the most
interesting and effective strategy and
then the third thing I'm going to talk
about is using machine learning and data
science really optimization ok powerful
optimization to directly learn what are
good sensors or actuators so I think
that's another very very interesting
thing we're going to talk about is
sensor and actuator placement and this
is historically a very hard problem
because if I have a million or billion
degrees of freedom choosing the best
five locations to measure is an
intractable combinatorially hard problem
but now again it's an optimization so
there are techniques to optimize those
sensor and actuator placements to get
you nearly optimal performance but are
very very fast and easy to implement ok
so this is the roadmap this is what
we're gonna do in this video lecture
series we're going to talk about
data-driven machine learning control
we're going to dive into using data
science for system identification
learning the system and this might not
be the full system this might be a
reduced order representation of just
those dominant coherent patterns that
matter so this might our model that we
obtain from data might be in terms of a
small state that just describes those
dominant patterns we're also going to
use machine learning directly to design
control laws and you know essentially
try different control strategies see
what works and refine in an iterative
and optimization process and then we're
also going to talk about how methods in
sparse optimization will allow us to
place nearly optimal sensors and
actuators for various objectives ok so
I'm really excited about telling you
about this new and emerging field and I
hope that you take these tool
and use them to solve really interesting
problems thank you